Voiceover: What I want to do in this
video is think a little bit about
how the unemployment
rate is actually computed
by the Bureau of Labor Statistics.
So to figure that out let's just start
off with the entire U.S. population.
So let me draw a big
circle here that represents
the entire U.S. population.
U.S. population and right now
if my numbers are correct,
the latest numbers are 304 million people.
Now, not all of those 304 million
people are capable of working,
including my two and a half year
old son or my newborn daughter
so you have to think of, when
you think about unemployment,
you want to think about the
percentage of these people
that are actually old enough to work.
That actually can be
employed theoretically.
So let's take a subset
of that U.S. population
and let's think about who's essentially
an adult, who's working age.
So this subset right over
here is 16 years and older,
so people who can legally work
and the numbers I have here
is that this is 100-
sorry, this right here
is 237 million people.
237 million people.
Now we can't just say all of
these people could possibly work
because a lot of them are in college,
some of them are in high school,
some of them might not
have the ability to work,
some of them might be retired.
So what we want to do is take
a subset of this population,
that is essentially part of the
labor force in that they are working
or they are actively looking for work.
So let me draw that right over here.
So this right over here
is the labor force.
Labor force, so these are not
retirees or people who are in college.
Those people would be sitting
right over there assuming
they're 16 years or older.
The labor force, so this is working or-
or I should say working and
actively looking for work,
and we'll think about what
actively looking for work means
in a little bit more
depth in a few minutes.
Actively looking for work.
And that number if my numbers are
correct is right around 154 million
although the numbers
here aren't so important,
the more important thing is
how the unemployment rate
itself is calculated.
And so then within the labor
force you have a subset,
so this is working and actively
looking for work, so you have a subset
of the labor force that is
actively looking for work.
So they don't have a job but
they're actively looking.
So this right here is
unemployed and actively looking.
Actively looking and this
actively looking is probably
more important than you
might realize at first.
And this number, let's just
say for the sake of argument,
this is sitting at
around 15 million people.
15 million people.
So if you have a job
you're right over here,
if you don't have a job
but are actively looking
you're going to be right over here.
What we're going to see in a little
bit is if you don't have a job
but you are not actively looking
but you could be working,
you would actually be sitting out here.
This is going to be
interesting when we think about
trends in the unemployment
rate when it goes up or down.
But just to see how the
unemployment rate is calculated,
let's just do it for this example.
So the unemployment rate-
unemployment rate is literally
just the number of unemployed
over the entire labor force.
So in this situation
it would be 15 million-
so that's just the number of
unemployed and actively looking
over the entire labor force.
Over 154 million and so if
we get my handy TI-85 out,
that gives us in this
example right over here,
an unemployment rate of
15 divided by 154 million.
So it's about 9.7, if we write
it as a decimal it's 0.097,
if we write it as a percentage
this would be 9.7 percent.
This is approximately 9.7 percent.
Now I told you that the details
are going to be important
and the reason why they are is
because interesting things happen
when people stop looking for work
or when they start looking for work.
So I said unemployed and actively looking
puts you in this bucket over here.
If you're unemployed,
if you don't have a job,
and you're not actively looking you're
actually not in the labor force.
And so you might be saying,
"Sal, what does it mean
"to be actively looking for work?"
And this means that you've looked for
a job or you are actively searching
in the past, let me do this in a
new color, in the past four weeks.
Past four weeks.
And you might say, "Sal, how do they
know whether these 15 million people
"have actively searched for
jobs in the past four weeks?"
And the answer is they do a survey.
They're not going to survey every
human being in the labor force
or the U.S. population or all
15 million that are unemployed,
that would be logistically impossible.
What they do is they do a
survey and right now they do
about 60,000 people every month
and they essentially ask them
are you employed, are you
unemployed, if you are unemployed
have you looked for a job
in the past four weeks?
If you have looked for a
job in the past four weeks
as an unemployed person you get
thrown into this bucket right here,
you're actively looking.
You're still part of the labor force.
But if you've gotten so discouraged
that you're no longer looking for work,
maybe you've given up, then you
get thrown out of the labor force.
And that is what most
people don't realize.
If things get bad enough and
people get really discouraged,
you have people actually
exiting the entire labor force.
To see how that affects the numbers,
imagine a situation.
So this is the unemployment
rate right now.
There's 15 million
people who are unemployed
and actively looking for work.
Let's say that this is just a
horrible recession or depression
and five million of these
people get so discouraged
they don't, in the last four weeks,
they do not look for work anymore.
So they maybe even stop altogether
or they want to take a break.
So what we're going to do is we're
going to take five million people
out of this bucket over here.
So we're going to take five
million people and move them
out over here, outside of the labor force.
If you did that, what happens?
Well now the official unemployed
number is now going to be 10 million,
it's now going to be 10 million.
And what's the labor force number?
Remember they went completely out
of this green circle over here.
So they've also left the labor force.
So the labor force number
is now 149 million.
So in this bad situation where
people have left the labor force
the unemployment rate would
now be 10 million people
unemployed and actively looking
for work over a labor force
of 149 million, the labor force has
shrunk because they're so discouraged.
So what do we get there
as our unemployment rate?
We have 10 divided by 149,
it gives us 6.7 percent.
So this is fascinating.
If things get bad enough and people
actually exit the labor force,
then the unemployment rate could go down
because the labor force is shrinking.
The other thing could also happen,
maybe things get really good,
maybe things get really good
and you have 10 million people
who are sitting out here, they're
either marginally attached workers
which are people who are hoping
to get a job but haven't looked
for a job in the past four weeks,
or they could be discouraged workers
who have altogether, they
wouldn't mind working,
but they've given up altogether
looking, but you can imagine it
when the economy gets good, let's say
we're starting from this baseline here,
when the economy gets good and all
of these people who are unemployed
but not part of the labor force all
of a sudden start looking for work.
So then they'd be part of
the official unemployed.
So this 10 million would
grow to 20 million,
20 million so now this
number is 20 million
and this green area would
go up by 10 million.
So now this would be 159 million.
So in this situation, the official
unemployed would be 20 million,
and the entire labor force
would be 159 million,
and now you would get a situation-
so you have 20 divided by 159 million,
which is 12.6 percent.
12.6 percent, approximately 12.6 percent.
So the whole point of this video, I'm
not saying that the unemployment rate,
the way it's calculated is wrong or
that's it supposed to be misleading,
I just want to give you a little
bit of nuance that it doesn't always
give the complete picture, in
particular that one number,
and there's other unemployment rates
that give a little bit more nuance here,
but this one headline unemployment rate
that is typically given on the news
doesn't capture the whole story.
In particular it doesn't
capture the people who might
be exiting the labor force
when things are bad, so in that
situation the unemployment rate
would probably be understating
how bad things are,
and it also doesn't capture the people
who are entering the labor force,
and that situation the unemployment
rate would probably make things
look worse than they are when
things might actually be improving.